four Armenian soldiers have been killed
in the disputed region of nikono
karabakh Azerbaijan and Armenia have
been holding talks mediated by the U.S
to end a decades-long conflict Armenian
prime minister has warned of a further
risk of destabilization if the issue is
not resolved there's been frequent
fighting on the border between the
neighbors
Alicia avatanum is a senior analyst for
the South Caucasus region at the crisis
group she joins us now live from Tbilisi
in Georgia good to have you with us on
the program I mean despite these peace
talks being hosted by the Americans is
everyone sort of holding their breath
after this incident because no one
really wants it to escalate
in fact uh there have been many
incidents taking place since the
beginning of Spring and this is not the
first time when we see clashes taking
place along the front lines the only
difference now is that with this
particular incident took place exactly
the time when Armenian and azerbaijani
foreign ministers and their delegation
they were sitting in front of each other
and discussing the peace talks it's
really very important to know that the
Americans are hosting the talks but they
are not mediating them and then it's of
course with sort of incidents they are
adding uh more problems and there is
kind of they are creating more difficult
environment there are many more people
back home are asking what what's uh you
know why are they there uh if if the
talks cannot really prevent with sort of
incidents indeed we saw Russia take a
pivotal role in getting the sides
together we talk about mediation they're
the ones that actually broken a
ceasefire as well Russia has been bogged
down really in the war in Ukraine it
some might say they've taken their eye
off the ball the U.S is replacing them
to some extent what's in it for the US
to get these sides to talk and to find
some sort of resolution
it's not really uh right to say that the
US is replacing them in fact since
Russia started its invasion of Ukraine
with uh with sort of diplomacy between
Armenia and Azerbaijan has stated out
any kind of interlocutors so in a way uh
what the United States are doing what
the European uh Union is are doing they
are in effect they are helping the size
to sustain their communication and to
continue talking to each other when
Russia has time they also do that in
fact Russia has a presence on the ground
they have a Russian peacekeeping Mission
uh present in the very conflict Zone but
with Russia being dragged so much in in
its war in Ukraine there is less and
less
um kind of dependency where there is
less eagerness from from Azerbaijan to
even pay attention to the fact that the
Russian peacekeepers are there I want to
jump in then because you know we keep
talking about Russia here in this
conversation what does Washington get
out of this I mean the US yes is hosting
these two sides to talk to each other
but they must want to see something
happen or else they wouldn't be
facilitating as hosts there must be a
reason for Washington to be involved
it's a very good question and then the
main reason why we see so many more
westerners and not just Americans but
also Europeans getting so involved
between Armenia and Azerbaijan is in
order to prevent another war in the
Russia's neighborhood there is a good
potential for that we saw fresh
Galatians last year each day later than
the other one so what we see now is
Americans and Europeans trying somehow
to find a way out somehow to prevent
with new work that will be so difficult
to address it's not only Russia that is
busy with the war in Ukraine which is
also the west and they definitely don't
want to see another bloody war taking
place in this part of the world it is a
certainly a worrying development though
there for the moment Alicia varton and
thanks so much for joining us from
Tbilisi in Georgia thank you for your
time